[Musik]
[Gelächter]
menschenrechte sind ziemlich abstoßend
ich würde dafür sollten wir uns heute
gemeinsam wieder tipps für unser
alltägliches leben unsere alltäglichen
probleme von der großartigen
ratgebersendung hilfe holen können ja
ich das heute morgen daran dachten wir
menschen welches alltägliche probleme
sollen wir denn heute mal besprechen
und da ist es mir eingefallen leute es
ist eigentlich glasklar wir besprechen
heute das alltagsproblem dass der eigene
vater mit der ex-freundin von einem
selbst eine beziehung startet ich denke
das ist eine situation hatten wir uns
alle wiederfinden und
[Musik]
also wieder junge der jetzt in dieses
zimmer kommt das ist glaube ich schon
dass eine beschreibung steht jonas ist
der sohn der vater heißt carsten und die
ex-freundin von jonas heißt janina so
janina es jetzt schon mal mit jonas
vater carsten zusammen wie gesagt das
ist das alltagsproblem was heute
diskutieren ja ja das kommt mit der
neuen schein nach hause und ja parallel
dazu legt seine halbnackte ex auf dem
sofa alles klar
übrigens leute jetzt hier an der stelle
weil ich das intro nicht allzu lang
machen wollte ich habe mein letztes jahr
ist michael paulo wieder runter genommen
weil ich da vorschnell geurteilt habe
und mich nicht richtig mit der situation
auseinandergesetzt habe bevor ich das
video gemacht habe
dafür muss mich entschuldigen und ja
videos jetzt offline genau und jetzt
geht weiter was machst du hier was
überhaupt an ersten nein kann ich nicht
die neue freundin von dem winter auf
jeden fall direkt zu den braten fragt
jedoch besser arrangiert hat also ja nie
aber wenn man muss aber auf jeden fall
sagen kompliment an rtl2 sie haben es
wirklich geschafft hier einen bezug zu
dieser thematik herzustellen der
wirklich sehr sehr leicht ist die
alltagssituation hilfe mein vater staat
etwas mit meiner ex wird hier noch
zugänglicher gemacht durch die noch
bekanntere alltagssituation man kommt
mit der neuen freundin nach hause und
die halbnackte ex liegt auf dem sofa
[Musik]
ja das hat gar nicht so lange gedauert
wir kriegen direkt den vorschlaghammer
hier voll die fresse und jetzt stehen
vater max jonas und neue freundin zu
führt immer noch der typ cologna nicht
klar
gott sei dank kommt würde er klar kommen
also der darsteller würde ich mir sorgen
machen er ist gott sei dank hier auch
[Musik]
wirklich heute ganze gesicht der muss
ich wirklich zusammen reich seine
situation aber er hat auch recht ich
meine klar ist es natürlich wieder der
alltagssituation jetzt hier präsentiert
wird ja nicht von schreiben oder so da
versuchen wir die story zu verdrehen
ja ja ich kann nicht der schluss gemacht
und seitdem natürlich nur terrorisiert
vater zusammen gekommen macht sie das
nur um mich zurück zu bekommen
ja das ist tatsächlich eine sehr weit
verbreitete taktik leute ich habe ja
auch einen recht großen anteil an mädels
da draußen ich habe 70 prozent von denen
oder 80 von denen wir gerade sehen sind
mir dass deswegen die frage an euch
mädels gibt es einfach zu ok also wir
vier männer haben wir haben euch ertappt
und das ist der einzige beweis dafür
dass die ja auch des öfteren aber ich
bin einfach mal
das kann man nicht mal laut sagen dass
man sich natürlich auch mal an den vater
des ex freundes macht und den ex-freund
zurückzubekommen
also haben wir glaube ich alle schon mal
gesehen hallo du kannst mit anpacken
mit dabei an wie deine ex freunde die
jetzt meine neue freundin ist bei uns
einzieht und ganz kurz anpacken also
vielleicht einfach so eine kiste trage
so ist ist ja kein problem für dich oder
du ziehst hier ein
ich kann auch weil hier 110 halo ist das
nicht genug lasse mich nicht da wo ich
ein platz frei sein oder war's ja immer
noch fragen leute das sind natürlich da
sind alle überlegungen die man anstellt
wenn man sich damit beschäftigt fährt
sich jetzt in meine wohnung ein
vollkommen egal welche beziehungen zu
dieser person davor hatte oder ob es
ratsam ist dass die person um einen
herum bund so lange genug platz ist in
der wohnung leute kann da jeder einzieht
ist kann das dein ernst sein jetzt ganz
im ernst
hallo was dazu ja diese frau die
verarscht dich nach strich und faden
hallo
ja aber proksa dem vater der sich blickt
sie über das was da abgeht
ja ja das ist kann ja das ist ja die
frau spricht aber ist mir egal
heidewitzka was ist denn der vater für
einen schlumpf wir haben es hier ja
offensichtlich mit einem rollentausch zu
tun das ist wohl die expertin ok
psychologin psychotherapeutin irgendwas
in der art heidewitzka was ist denn der
vater für einen schlumpf heidewitzka was
ist denn der vater von schlumpf das ist
wirklich die korrekte psychologische
diagnose hier in diesem fall die gute
frau hat wirklich einen messerscharfen
verstand und hatte sofort erkannt dass
hier alle symptome vom schlumpf sein
vorliegen und zögert dann einfach nicht
die diagnose raus sorgen heidewitzka was
ist der vater von schlumpf
macht das doch nur wegen mir um mir eins
auszuwischen das ist wirklich eine geile
herangehensweise ans leben so ja ich
wollte doch nur dass alles schön wird
und dann habe ich mich gefragt was kann
ich machen und damit am besten mein
persönliches leben und das leben von
allen menschen um mich herum schön wird
und da ist es mir klar geworden
ich fange beziehung mit dem vater meines
ex freundes an dann wird es für alle
schöne kleine rohde
[Musik]
er ist klar geht es am nächsten morgen
zur arbeit so junge kollegen stetiger ja
alles klar weil ja ja ja was gibt es
neues audi regal nicht so viel so meine
ex ist jetzt mit meinem vater zusammen
ja aber die wollten nur dass alles schön
wird nee da muss man wirklich sagen
sollte das ist jetzt mal beruhigen also
schön und gut zur probleme ansprechen so
die inneren bedürfnisse äußern keine
ahnung irgendwie sachen die einem
persönlich wichtig sind zum thema machen
ok schön und gut ja macht es meinetwegen
digger aber sobald auch nur ein kleines
bisschen die stimmung darunter leidet
könnte sich mit einem problem verpissen
okay das aller wichtigste im leben ist
eine gute stimmung
egal welche psychische probleme damit
herum trägt hauptverdächtigen passt der
junge jonas ist von duschen und auch
klassiker die mitbewohnerin kommt
einfach ins bad rhein werde man dann
duschen ist macht einfach mal so den
duschen aufzuheitern
durch weiter ich wollte nur sagen wir
brauchen mal wieder scheuermilch also
wir sind mittlerweile so weit dass es
tatsächlich für mich sogar als nur
jemand der diese folge dokumentiert
schon schwierig wird die ganzen fehlen
dir zusammen zu bringen als auch seine
ex freundin ist jetzt auch neuerdings
seine stiefmutter scheinbar haben die
schon geheiratet
mit seinem vater ja dadurch befindet
sich jonas jetzt in der folgende
situation und das ist ganz wichtig dass
wir wirklich aufpassen weil da können
wir viel für unser eigenes leben daraus
lernt wenn ihr in der situation sein
sollte dass euer vater mit eurer etwas
anfängt diese ex dann auch eure
stiefmutter wird also ihre exporteure
stiefmutter die euch dann im bad während
ihr duschen überrascht und euch einen
putzplan aufdrücken will ok wenn alle
diese fälle eintreten was sehr oft der
fall ist dann
möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen aber eine szene dieser folge
wichtigen leute haltet euch fest und
zwar jetzt ein zwei szenen später
passiert passiert wir uns noch gelebt
das ist ja jetzt wohl der punkt wo sich
die regisseure gedacht haben okay wir
wollen wirklich kategorisch ausschließen
dass hier irgendjemand mit einem
gesunden gegnern aus dieser folge raus
gibt das wollen wir wirklich verhindern
und deswegen hat jetzt seine ex die sein
vater geheiratet hat wieder was mit ihm
[Musik]
also wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin muss ich
sagen ich bin froh dass diese folge
jetzt worum es ich weiß nicht was
irgendjemand als rat aus dieser folge
ziehen soll ganz ehrlich ich habe mich
angestrengt was zu finden ich konnte
nichts finden
aber ok ratgeberserie ich habe hier
immer leute hier drücken dann für euch
vorgeschlagen dass wir hier oben könnt
ihr meinen kann aber den zuschauern die
bessere augen macht's gut